I would just say this is the the one
concert on this storm you know the track
has been here or there and there's been
a lot of uncertainty but the one thing
that's been pretty certain is that this
thing's been getting stronger very
consistently and completely in line with
all the forecasting and so we anticipate
this arriving somewhere in Florida as a
major hurricane it could reach for
category 4 plus winds you know that is a
significant significant storm that will
lead to really significant storm surge
obviously has the possibility of having
significant wind damage and destruction
but I would also say to folks you know
if you're in an area that has flooded in
past storms like Burma you know this is
a slow-moving storm you know you're
almost assuredly to experience flooding
if this thing comes across and impacts
you so so take preparations understand
that that could happen understand that
you're likely to lose power and act
accordingly so the time to act is now
this storm is slower than thought of
four or five days ago which means you
know we're looking at I think the
tropical storm force winds probably
coming sometimes Sunday night so make
the preparations that you need you do
have some time but that time is running
out I mean with that I'm happy to take
some questions we have not we have not
decided to do that I think for several
reasons I mean one is we're still
bringing in things to assist with the
storm have you noticed in the with with
the fuel we're constantly having trucks
being refueled at the ports and then
going to fill up these key tanks at the
gas stations we've also gotten Georgia
Alabama and Mississippi to waive their
weight restrictions on trucks so that we
can bring in more fuel from out of state
so that is happening you have some
places I think Miami 48% of the gas
stations were out as of this morning
fuel is constantly being brought in
there's other assets that are being
brought in to where the storm would be
so to close off all that traffic it's
probably not the way we want to go right
now but also I would note we don't see a
lot of necessarily abnormal traffic
right at this minute as of this morning
now as orders come down for evacuation
you know that of course will change but
I think it's also important and I was
talking to the county officials here in
Palm Beach County you know they really
recommend evacuating locally they have
shelters that are hurricane that are
built to withstand hurricanes it makes
it much easier to be able to do that and
so if you are in an area where you're
told to evacuate know where your
shelters are know the different options
that you have it doesn't have to be
everyone in the east coast of Florida
gets on i-95 and just keeps driving you
know we know this storm is coming in a
westerly posit westerly direction we
know it eventually turned north we don't
really know where it's gonna turn north
precisely and you could end up you know
even driving into the storm if you if
you take that route so but yes we're
gonna have the shoulders open so that
will allow for an increased flow of
traffic so the the water levels have our
lower than they've typically been I mean
part of that is things that that we were
working with the federal government on
really to try to obviate some of the
environmental damage that was being
caused by the discharges you know that
said you're looking at a potentially
significant significant amount of
rainfall and so we're in contact with
the Army Corps they reported to me
yesterday that they had you know
capacity for another four feet but you
know these things storm of this
magnitude and particularly how slow it's
going you know has a capacity to dump an
awful lot of water into the lake and so
we are in a situation where if the lake
gets to a certain level you know they
obviously have their different protocols
of how they deal with that with
federal government yeah no I mean
obviously I think that exacerbates it I
mean you look at some areas you know I
was you know seeing some of the images
out of Jupiter where the water is
already up to the dock in some of those
places we also have other parts of the
state places like Dixie County that have
been experiencing flooding Pasco County
so even if they're on the outer bands of
the storm you know they're gonna be in a
situation where you absolutely see water
levels rise and so when you have a
strong storm obviously the wind can
cause a lot of damage as we saw in
Hurricane Michael it obviously leads to
a lot of storm surge which can be
life-threatening but in terms of the
broadest impacts of the storm very very
likely to be because of the flooding and
so that's just something people need to
need to understand and I would also say
is that as this storm comes as the water
rises you know be very very careful
about how you're going into this I mean
every storm we if people try to drive
through flooded streets and their cars
end up end up getting stuck and that
that's what's gonna happen so so please
please be very cautious with the water
well know so that the state is taking
the taking visits to some of them
some of them are being contacted via
phone now not all of them are in the
path of the storm and so like in Palm
Beach you know the vast vast majority of
them have have complied and so what
we're doing is we're informing local
officials we're informing them that
they're not meeting their obligations
and and obviously now's the time to make
alternative arrangements I mean you and
and you know I'm glad that this case
came down in Brower I'm but it glad it
happened but I'm glad those people are
being held accountable because I think
that sends the message now gonna in this
storm if you have vulnerable people in
your care it's your responsibility to
make sure that though that you have a
plan in place to protect those folks I
mean you know at this point you could
lose power and so so what are you going
to do
if that ends up happening and so you
know that is really where it was
responsible we've also had I mean
where's Eric Salah GFP L you know
they've written letters to all the
nursing facilities about about this I
don't think any of them responded to you
to FB and L did they so some of them
just haven't done that and so you know
at the end of the day we have a site now
where you can go and click on a county
and it has all the stats and everything
and and so you know where the potential
problems are but these folks have gotta
have got to step up and protect these
folks